all right guys how many of you have
played pac-man before almost everyone
and how many of you consider yourselves
as good pac-man players so we have a
couple of liars in the room that's good
to know we we and we play a lot of
pac-man but we're pretty bad at it and
we saw an opportunity using
reinforcement learning to make an agent
that plays pac-man and wha-la this
workshop was was born
welcome to reinforcement learning
pac-man so before we continue I would
like to get to know you guys just a
little bit since we're at the University
I'm going to assume that there are going
to be students here and there if you
were a student a few students and rest
of you are IT professionals I'm going to
assume sounds kids were a diverse set of
people that is great so let's begin now
this was originally a three to four hour
long workshop where we would present
some theory about a couple of
reinforcement learning methods before we
would let the participants work on some
tasks and play around do some coding and
train an agent to play the classic game
of pac-man now we don't do not have that
much time today so we're gonna do things
a little bit differently then how we
usually do this so we're going to
present the same kind of theory but the
format is going to be more like a
walkthrough where we kind of do the
workshop on screen in front of you but
we have also made the material available
so we will give you access to the
environment where you can code as well
so that you can follow along and code if
you want to but this is of course not
necessary if you just want to sit back
and watch us do the work on screen so
let's take a look at the agenda of the
day we will start out with a brief
introduction to reinforcement learning
explaining terminology and concepts with
a few examples and then we will begin
doing
we'll start building the first
reinforcement learning model based on
something called Q learning which we
will also explain how that works and
then the second model we will build will
be based on deep Q learning which means
Q learning with neural networks so I
don't know how many of you have worked
with neural networks before so we're
going to at least to a small refresher
going through the basics so that you
understand what we're working on before
we begin let us tell you guys a little
bit of ourselves
my name is Malta
I am from Denmark I'm currently working
at the Nordic consultancy firm called
knowit it's originally from Sweden but
they have bought up some other companies
in Oslo so we're sitting in Oslo in
Norway I've been working there for two
and a half years now and I started
working there directly after I graduated
I did my masters at the new Norwegian
University of Science and Technology and
during that time also did one year at
UCSB in Santa Barbara here California I
did it focusing on computer science and
artificial intelligence my Master's
right now I'm a project at V which is
the Norwegian railroad company where we
are a little team that sets the prices
for the tickets so if you guys go to
Norway and you think it's really very
expensive with the tickets you know how
to blame it's me and we use a bit of
machine learning there to predict how
many tickets we're gonna sell so we can
adjust the prices accordingly alright my
name is Manu and I'm from Norway for the
past few years I've been actually
following basically the same path that's
Malta we used to study together at the
Norwegian University of Technology and
we also I was also at UCSB for a year
and now I also work at the same firm as
he does know it currently I'm out
sourced to a company called m2 it
which is a Norwegian for one trip is a
government-owned company in Norway and
their mission is to collect all the
sales and ticketing solutions for public
transportation in Norway making it
possible to travel anywhere in normally
using just one single app basically so
it's pretty cool and before that I did
my master's thesis with in machine
learning doing natural language
processing on tweets to predict the
gender of authors that's you thank you
okay so how many of you guys work with
machine learning in your daily life Oh
quite a bit actually that's cool and how
many of you work with reinforcement
learning not so many how many of you
have worked a little bit on one hobby
basis with reinforcement learning okay
so we will go through all the basics
then so machine learning is a branch of
AI and AI is kind of a broad topic which
means to make the computer do something
intelligent and that's also the goal
with machine learning but machining has
two additional properties namely that
the that uses data to train its models
and it's not explicitly programmed to
solve one single problem so for instance
a neural network learns solely based on
the data fed to it and therefore it can
kind of solve any problem based on this
data yes and one thing that's also so
machine learning is also divided into
three parts supervised learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning minors can talk a little bit
about that later but one important thing
to notice is that reinforcement learning
it creates its data on the fly while
usually supervised learning and
unsupervised already have pre created
data sets so let's talk a little bit
about reinforcement learning
recentiy reinforcement learning has
really like taken
there's a lot of hype about it all kind
of started back in 2013 I believe when
google deepmind made a bot that plays
atari with superhuman performance and
from there just took off then they made
alpha zero which beats the world best
players in chess shogi and go then open
AI five made a reinforcement learning
system that beat the world's best
players in dota 2 and then google
deepmind again made alpha star which
beat the world best players in starcraft
2 but reinforcement learning is not only
used in games the games are merely a
stepping stone before entering the real
world and it has been used in the real
world to control traffic signals it's
been used to predict financial markets
it's used in medicine and also to
accelerate human learning yes so there
are kind of five terms we need to know
before we start going deeper into the
material the first one is agent and an
agent is a unit that performs actions so
for instance it could be a drone making
a delivery
or it could be Super Mario navigating a
videogame the second term is action and
the action is something that the agent
does for instance in Super Mario he can
run to the left he can run to the right
he can jump and so on the third term is
the environment and it is the world
where the agent moves persons in Super
Mario the environment is just a complete
game right in real world their
environment is the laws of physics and
society that deems whether your actions
are good or bad then there is the state
which is a concrete and immediate
situation where the agent find itself
and puts it in relation to enemies and
rewards and stuff it's very often a
function of time so you can think about
it as if you stop the time you're in a
given state and then give you a couple
of examples later
and then lastly we have the rewards
which is the feedback what that we
measure our success or failure of our
agents actions so for instance in a
video game when Mario touches the coin
or he wins the game he gets a good
reward but when he dies he probably gets
a negative reward or a punishment so we
can kind of look look at it with this
figure if we start on the left you have
a state and a reward
this is fed to the agent and the agent
then performs an action in this state
they actually performed into the
environment and the environment returns
the reward and the next state for that
and then this loop continues until an
episode is terminate its terminated so
let's just look at an example here is
the Super Mario walking around we have
stopped the time just took a screenshot
he's in currently in this given state
and when he's in that state he has
gotten a reward and he knows which state
he's in now it's time to pick his action
if you guys can see it I'm gonna go to
the next state now he chooses to go to
the right so actions to what to the
right was the first state as the next
one just walks through right to the
environment then gives back the next
state and a reward the reward here is
probably just nothing because nothing
really happened and so on continues
until he either and to Mario dies or he
wins the level there are a couple of
challenges of reinforcement learning
the two biggest ones are the exploration
versus exploitation challenge and the
second one is delayed or future rewards
so for the first one I'm gonna use my
puppy as an example so this summer I got
a puppy it's a golden retriever do any
dog people here you can think of him as
kind of an agent that tries to maximize
his own rewards and what you need to
know is that I live on the
apartment on the third floor so when you
go out of my apartment you go down the
hallway and you reach the the ground
level you have to open the door and then
you can either walk to the left or walk
to the right and if you walk to the left
you walk to the back yard if you walk to
the right you go out on the street so
when he was very little we just took him
to the back yard all the time so we
walked to the left and now when we then
open the door
he only walks to the left because he
know there's the back yard and he really
likes to sit there and chew on his
sticks in the backyard and that's what
kind of what puppies do they always just
try to exploit exploit every situation
choose the best reward on a very
short-sighted notice and so for him to
know that walking to the right is also
good we have to show him that so we
showed him and he also it he also likes
the walk out on the street on a walk so
the way you solve this is that if you
only choose the path that gives you the
max reward in a short term then your
agent is not going to learn to search
the whole state space so this is often
solved by just by a small random
probability you perform a random action
so that when for instance puppy walks to
the left at some point there's going to
be a small probability that is also
going to be walked to the right and he's
going to look at the right path and then
you'll look at all the rewards over
there and then he can make a better
choice later when he is fully trained
yeah the second one the delayed rewards
or future rewards is that when you tell
him to get down you give a treat because
he did something that is correct and the
reward is associated with good behavior
now if you wait too long to give the
treat he might for instance have laid
down and then for instance looked to the
left and if you give the treat after you
look to the left then he's going to
think that it was because he looked to
the left that made him that was the good
behavior so now every time when you say
down he'll just
down and you look to the left and then
you give the treat and that's wrong so
he also just start walking around just
suddenly look to the left as he's gonna
get a treat then but this is only one
example and there's many others it can
be very difficult for an agent in a
video game to learn that something you
did very early in the game maybe one use
the game like a hundred thousand time
steps later and this is one a challenge
you have to to take care of and then we
can go over to cue learning so hopefully
you now have a basic understanding about
what reinforcement learning is about and
the first model we're going to build
will be based on something called cue
learning so what is Q learning it's an
algorithm which learns Q values for
state action pairs in the environment
and what does that mean well for each
possible state you have a set of
possible actions and for each of these
actions it will learn a cue value a cue
value is a measure of utility or quality
of an action in a given state it's a
measure of how good it is so the higher
it is the better you can view it as an
estimate of the amount of total reward
that is possible to obtain in the end by
picking this action now in this state so
in more practical terms it's a way of
measuring how happy will this action act
actually make you in the end so when you
have a fully trained Q learning model
the agent will perform the action with
the highest Q value so let's take a look
at a practical example now let's say
that you find yourself at the PI data
conference and that smiley face right
there that's you in state zero now after
a long day at the conference you are
looking forward to getting to maybe the
Staples Center in
state it because there's a Lakers game
or you know Trevor Noah is doing a show
or maybe it's noot dog whatever is your
thing you're looking forward to getting
there in Hanvey and having a cold beer
or something now let's assume that
you've never been to Los Angeles before
so you know and you don't have a map
either so you're going to roam around
these squares until you find the place
now to be able to learn from your
mistakes and also your correct decisions
we need a measure for success and that's
what rewards are for right
so what kind of rewards do we have here
let's say that if you get to the Staples
Center that's 20 points and then on the
way there you could end up at hobbling
race we just heard about howling raisins
people told us that you get the best
wings around there and so we're really
looking forward to that if you guys
disagree you guys got to find us after
the tutorial so that we can talk about
for to find the best wings anyway how in
raised five points right
you can also end up in the river and
that's not a good idea that's minus 20
points because winter is coming and it's
getting colder actually it's not really
that cold here in LA compared to back
home where it's freezing right now but
anyway you also have a move penalty of
minus one and we need this because let's
say you're really Thursday so you really
want that beer so you want to get to the
Staples Center as fast as possible if
you don't have a move penalty you might
just you know take a walk and spend too
much time getting there so this is like
a motivation for that and also because
practice makes perfect you will try to
find the Staples Center multiple times
many times and each try is called an
episode now squares four and eight
they're called terminal States this is
where an episode ends and then you start
again a new episode now we need to keep
track of these Q values they're gonna
change during training we need a way to
keep track of them so we're gonna do
this by using a dictionary
so for each state and for each action
there will be a value in the dictionary
so in the beginning of this dictionary
is going to be empty meaning that the Q
values are all initialized to zero so we
don't really know anything about them
and then following an execution of an
action the Q value for the state needs
to be updated with the new information
gained in the next state so I said the
next state it means that you pick an
action which you perform in this state
like go left and then you end up in the
next step right and there there will be
some kind of report and you need to
update the Q values using this
information and we will do this using
this complicated looking formula which
isn't really that complicated we just
got to break it apart just a little bit
so that we understand what we're facing
here so essentially we just take the old
Q value for the state action pair and
then we add the reward that we received
in the next state so if you end up at
how Lin race you get five points that's
a reward there then you also add the
estimate of optimal future value which
is a fancy way of saying take the
highest Q value in the next state
because that is the action that is going
to make you the most happy from the next
state right and then you also subtract
the old Q value in the formula you also
see a couple of constant factors that's
the Alpha and the gamma also known as
the learning rate and the discount
factor if you worked with machine
learning before you've probably seen the
learning rate before perhaps not the
discount factor this is used to scale
down the Q value for the next state we
do this because we value the immediate
reward received now more than the
potential reward that we might receive
later on so the five points for how in
race that just we just add that
instantaneously but we scale down that
maximum Q value that we pick from the
next state
the learning rate is a scaling factor
used to scale down the entire update
value so during training we want to
update the Q values iteratively and
slowly so that we can gradually close in
on the after mo Q values so if you if we
do not scale down the Q values may
change too much at each step and the mom
wouldn't learn anything useful so these
were usual to do machine learning which
you probably already know so let's do a
test run right so in the beginning there
are two possibilities right from state
zero you could go to either state one or
state three right so in the beginning
since all of the Q values are all 0
you're just going to pick a random
action so let's say we end up in state 3
and now we need to update the Q value
for picking state 3 from state 0 so
we'll just use this formula it's all
about plotting in the values that we
already know and we have to set a
discount factor and also learning rate
these are parameters that are usually
tuned during machine learning training
and this is the same formula just that
now we have plotted in the variables for
the update step that we're about to do
so the new Q value is going to be you
take the old Q value of 0 then you add
the learning rate multiplied by the
reward received which is minus 1 in
state 3 because nothing really happened
there so there's the move penalty plus
the discount factor multiplied by the
maximum Q value in state 3 which is the
state you ended up here and this is also
0 at this point and then you subtract
the old Q value which is also 0 and then
you get a new Q value of minus 0.2 so we
update the dictionary and then it kind
of makes sense that the Q value is
negative at this point because nothing
good has really
happened yet right so if we continue and
do and move on to state six then we see
that the action of going to state 6 from
state 3 it's a positive Q value because
something positive happened right and
then we can just continue you move on to
the state 7 we update the Q value but
then at some point we'll end up in a
terminal state and you see that there's
a massive boost in the Q value for going
to state 8 from state 7 because the
reward in state aid is so huge compared
to the ones who've had before and since
we're at the terminal state now the
episode is done and then we start a new
episode and this time we might end up
here because now the Q value if we're
going to state 1 is actually larger than
the Q value for going to state 3 because
going to say 3 is now minus 0.2 while
going to state 1 is 0 which is higher
right now we might end up in the river
and then the episode is done and this
goes on this goes on until the algorithm
converges on the optimal values to a
point where the path from the University
to the Staples Center is so clear right
and when the path doesn't change anymore
then the model has converged this is
just an algorithm we just defines
everything I just talked about because I
already did but I just want to make a
few points this step is called
exploration which multi talked about for
some random probability there is a
likelihood that we're just going to pick
a random action no matter the Q values
no matter how good they're in otherwise
we will exploit the knowledge that we
already possess and we'll choose the
action with the highest Q value for the
state for in and why do we do this
well if you look here there are actually
two paths to the terminal state right
you could go through state three six and
seven or you can go through one two and
five and obviously it's better to go
through state six where you'll get
chicken wings on the way right because
if you go through one two and five
you'll end up at the Staples Center
really hungry and it's not the best path
it's actually a sub optimal path right
here so it's you know it will take you
to where you want to go but this way is
better and if you don't explore you
might not find this path with that said
I think we're going to start doing some
coding so we're going to use Python and
later we're also going to use carrots
and tensorflow
for the deep cue part tends to follow
you out some of you are probably used
before Google's deep learning framework
caris is a wrapper around that to make
it a little bit more user friendly now
for the coding part there are actually
two parts the first part is done using
two pure notebooks how many I'm gonna
have used to appear before based almost
all of you that's great so you know that
it's an online interface for working
with the code and and running it and all
that
we'll use this to write the
implementation and train the models
using the GPU in the cloud
and you will also be able to do this
while I'm doing it because we'll give
you access to the interface through this
URL which you can all go to right now
and using the username written on that
piece of paper that is so nicely cut out
for you you can log in on your separate
users password is a is cool and you'll
get your own copy of the the notebooks
so I'll just give you like 15 seconds to
do that
in the second part we will watch the
trained model play pac-man but we will
have to do this locally on our machines
because well we haven't made the the GUI
available through Jupiter so we'll have
to download the trained model and then
we'll run it locally which is from this
github project so if you've set it up
beforehand that's great and if not and
if you were not able to do it now then
we're going to leave all this open for
the rest of day I guess so that you can
play around with it later as well if you
if you'd like to do that and otherwise
you can just sit back and watch watch
the show everyone got the screen all
right
so if you log in you'll end up in this
screen and then the the folder you were
gonna use is called ml pac-man Jupiter
you'll just get in there and then you'll
see all these notebooks and it also it
also seen some Pike Python files and
those are just like helper methods and
stuff that we'll use in the notebooks
and we've also bundled the pac-man game
which value of our said work created he
created like his own version because you
want to try out the graphical stuff so
we just bundled that in a notebook as
well but we're mostly going to be
working on the side assignment files I'm
just gonna show you what it looks like
like the game before we start because it
doesn't look like normal pac-man
for some reason he didn't he didn't
create it that way is they're all able
to see or is it like is it there's a
possible light dim the light here or so
this is what the pac-man game looks like
it's basically you know the same game it
just doesn't doesn't have like a yellow
guy running around we're gonna do a deep
let's let's look at the map we're
actually going to Train on for the cue
learning model is going to be a little
bit smaller because Q learning is very
sensitive to the size of state space so
basically the size of the map so this is
a much smaller map we're gonna create a
model for that alright let's get back to
okay so most of you have already worked
with notebooks before so sorry don't
need to sue yep
that good all right
so notebooks you probably know how it
works you have these code cells that we
can run then the star shows up here it
means that it's running and then when
that number shows up it means that it's
done executing the code within the cell
so in this cell were just importing
packages that we need for the rest of
this assignment the first thing we're
going to do is define the rewards for
each of the events that can occur while
playing pacman
so the values for these rewards is all
about it's about trying different values
and then seeing if it works it's like
hyper parameters that you tune right the
important thing here is that you want to
balance the values in relation to each
other right you need to somehow
represent the importance of each event
and how much they mean so we're not
going to do any experimentation right
now I'm just gonna plot in the values
that we've found beforehand that seem to
work all right so when you pick up a dot
you'll get reward of two and then if you
were captured by a ghost that's a bad
thing
minus five if nothing happens meaning
that you just move and you don't pick up
a dot you just actually just move in the
game then it's basically a move penalty
here of minus 0.1 and then if you crash
into a wall it's basically the same as
not doing anything if you win we need to
boost the rewards to represent the
significance of this so we give that a
20 if you lose let's say minus 10 right
and then we shift enter to run the cell
then we just move on we initialize the
cue table here to an empty dictionary
and then while training we will populate
the dictionary with the States and the Q
values for the actions as we train so
most many of these methods have we have
already implemented fully because there
is a lot of just procedure
so I'm just going to explain them and
then we'll move on and do most of the
coding will be on the actual machine
learning aspects so this method is just
for picking the optimal action given a
state so the optimal action for a state
you'll find that by looking up the state
in the Q table then you find the action
with the highest Q value right but
picking an action itself for each state
you're in is not about just picking the
most optimal action you will also have
to have this exploration probability
right so for so we will set this to 0.2
so that means there is a 20% chance that
you will disregard the Q values and
you're just going to pick a random
action and see where it gets you so for
a ran for a certain probability there is
likelihood of picking a random action so
we'll get all the actions
and then will return a random action
otherwise we'll exploit our knowledge in
our cue table or cue dictionary and then
we'll just use the function that's
already defined above like this and this
method just picks the maximum Q value
for a given state we're going to use it
later on in the training function so we
now we basically define all the
functions that are needed to train a Q
learning model so the training function
it has two arguments here at the level
the map that we're going to train on and
the number of episodes that we want to
train for so we begin by initializing
the game state to the starting point and
then we need to define the gamma and the
Alpha the gamma is the same as the
discount we'll just set it to zero point
eight and the Alpha will set to zero
point two and for each episode we need
to do a certain number of steps so each
step asad starts at the starting point
right so we will just initialize the
game state and then we need to pick an
action given the game state the current
game state so pick action and then we
will use this helper method from the
pac-man game package which given the
current game state and the action that
you decide to execute you will get the
new game state and also the
event that occurs when you perform that
action so if you won because you picked
up all the dots or if you lose because
you lost our lives as the ghosts
captured you then the episode is done
and it will move on to the next episode
right we need to calculate the reward
given the action event which will do
like this this is the method that we
defined in the very beginning and then
we have to define the update step we
need to implement the q-value update
step which is based on this function
right which i explained earlier so what
we do is we take the old Q value and
then we add the learning rate which is
defined as alpha I believe multiplied by
the reward that we received plus the
discount factor times the maximum Q
value in the next state the new game
state so we'll really use this method
compute I think it's called computing
max Q value okay that's a new game state
all right
[Music]
- the old q-value now this could have
been written a lot more cleanly with
variables and stuff but this is not a
clean code the tutorials I guess we're
fine and then we were basically done and
we can run this cell and see if it is
able to execute fine looks like it this
part yeah sure yeah it's basically the
same as the first first part here and
then we will just try it up will train
for 250 episodes so just we just we're
just doing some print outs here to see
that it's actually able to learn and we
can actually see that it's learning more
and more for each four as the number of
iterations increase 250 episodes doesn't
take that much time so it's done
training and the model is now stored in
the file called cue table in the same
folder and what we can do now is we can
download this file and then we'll move
on to the other project and inside the
package called Jupiter where we
basically bundled everything that's
going on in the rest of the project
we've bundled everything we need in here
instead and we go into the Jupiter main
file and then what you can do is you can
like drag the file inside the Jupiter
package which I've already done so I'm
not going to do that again now and then
we can run the game and see how it
performs
and we only ran it for okay that's the
wrong wrong button that we only ran it
for 250 episodes which is not that much
so here we see that it's actually doing
quite fine that's interesting it was
supposed to be really bad okay let's run
again you can just put it in the Jupiter
package right here just drag it in here
yeah because the path is already defined
in the Jupiter main file yeah yeah yeah
at the bottom you can comment in the
play q-learning model instead of I'm
going to download the model I just
trained because maybe the model I have
in my package is a little bit better
than I thought it was
[Music]
[Music]
sorry in my terminal I didn't go in my
terminal do you mean like in here I like
in the idea at oh yeah I just no I just
I just used a hot key for running the
the file but you can just like
right-click and you have to remain and
then run it and then it will actually
run yeah so we're gonna try this again
and see what happens okay now it's okay
okay when I ran this at home it was
really bad and I was gonna make a point
out of all you gotta train it more you
know for like five thousand episodes but
now it seems like it's actually doing
pretty well so I think we can just move
on to the next part which will be about
deep deep cue learning where we will be
able to run like train a model for
bigger maps because Q learning is
actually it's very sensitive to the size
of the state space so for bigger maps it
will be really hard to train it will
take a long time and deep Q learning is
less sensitive towards this so for the
deep Q learning model we will be able to
run and watch it playing on that bigger
map that I showed you earlier
[Music]
but in general the point I was trying to
make is that if you only train it for a
few iterations then it's not going to be
as good as if you train it for a longer
time especially when the problem becomes
very complex and the map is more
difficult then you have to train for a
longer time to get a good result before
we get to the deep q-learning part I'm
just going to I need to change my
display here sorry before we get to the
deep Q learning part I want to briefly
talk about supervised learning because
there is an aspect of supervised
learning in in the deep Q learning even
though it's different from reinforcement
learning in general but there are a lot
of people who had already worked with
machine learning before so many of you
have worked with supervised learning
okay there's a fraction of people here
I'm just going to explain very briefly
not too many details but just like the
main idea here so supervised learning is
used for predictive modeling given a set
of input features you want to predict a
certain outcome now there are many
different algorithms which differ in
their approaches to learning but they
all have income that they intend to
learn a target function f of X which can
map input variables X to an output Y
this function is based on examples from
the domain you want to predict and the
first step in supervised learning
concerns the data it's basically the
first step in most machine learning
methods I guess to train a supervised
learning model you need data set of
examples from the problem space that
you're trying to predict right so say
you want to predict the market value of
cars right then you need a data set
describing different
individual cars through a structured
representation and this representation
could be to make Marvel mileage and the
year of the car you could use this to
describe one instance of car right
additionally each data sample also needs
to be labeled what was it a car actually
sold for right and that's why it's
called supervised learning because you
act as a guide or a teacher for the
algorithm by providing the answers to
each example it's come to say that more
examples that you have in your data set
the better but I'd like to say that
what's most important is that the data
set covers the problem space as much as
possible
which means that you know this often
mean place that the more data you have
the more likely you are to cover the
problem space next the training set is
fed to the learning algorithm based on
the examples of the cars and the correct
labels the algorithm tries to capture
patterns and approximate that function
of predicting the market price of cars
now our goal by doing all this is for
the model to generalize the problem of
pretty predicting the market price of
cars so that you can predict the market
price of any car cars that the model
hasn't seen before that's the whole
point of this right
that's very briefly a surprise learning
let's talk about about artificial neural
networks which we're going to use for
deep Q learning we've been hearing a lot
about it lately you know you got all
these big companies doing all this crazy
stuff with neural networks image
recognition speech recognition you have
Grand Master's of chess being beaten by
machines it's pretty cool today we're
going to use this for pac-man how many
of you have worked with neural networks
previously there are some of you okay
I'm not going to go into like grande
detail
not like technical details but just like
the basic stuff to understand what a
neural network actually does I thought
I'd break down the black box of neural
networks with some simple examples now
this can be viewed as a very simple
neural network we only have one input
variable the engine power of the car and
then you have an output of price as the
output and then that circle in the
middle there that's a neuron naturally
neural networks
consists of neurons you know following
that and oil analogy of how neurons and
human brain process information
now this neuron executes some kind of
function on the engine power to predict
the price let's expand this a little bit
further now we could say that the engine
power and the weight of a car could say
something useful about the speed of a
car I'd like if the car is heavier then
it's going to be slower and if the
engine power is greater then it's going
to be faster right so we could say that
the speed is an inferred abstraction
from the engine power and the weight
furthermore given the seat fabric and
the amount of leg space in a car we
could say that we could say something
about level of comfort that a car
provides now these two inferences are
high-level abstractions that a network
may be able to learn if we put all this
together we get a neural network with
multiple layers through multiple layers
a neural network has the potential to
learn the relationships between inputs
in one layer and then infer high-level
abstractions that it can pass on to the
next layer so given these four input
variables the network may be able to
infer information about level of comfort
and the speed of car which again may
narrow down the task of predicting the
price of a car this is the input layer
the number of neurons in the input layer
directly correspond
to the number of features used to
represent a data sample in your data set
so here we have four features so we have
four neurons the number of neurons in
the output layer depends on the problem
that you're trying to solve so this is
essentially a regression problem where
you have a continuous numerical value as
output representing the price but when
we're going to use this for pac-man then
we're trying to predict the action that
you want to execute given a state an
impact menu have four possible actions
which are the directions that you want
to move so you will have four output
neurons representing these four classes
of actions right this is the hidden
layer this is essentially where the
magic happens neural network can have an
arbitrary number of hidden layers it can
also have an arbitrary number of neurons
in the in layers and these are
parameters that you want to try out
different values for to find the most
optimal architecture for your problem
now the reason why it's called a hidden
layer is that because in reality it
looks more like this because the
high-level abstractions that it learns
are not visible to us we can just
hypothesize but what it learns we don't
really know what's going on in here
which is also why we have to make this
illustration a little bit more
complicated since we don't know what
kind of concepts the network learns we
just feed all the neurons in each layer
every neuron in the previous layer and
then we just cross our fingers and then
we hope that please learn something to
solve my problem right I think I'll give
this to you now so that you can talk
about deep Q learning so why is deep Q
learning really a thing why do you use
neural networks for this the reason is
memory
acquirement if you have a cue table your
memory requirement is an array of states
times actions for instance with a state
space of five there are five different
states you can be in and an action space
of two which means you have two actions
to pick from the total memory
consumption is 2 times 5 which is 10 the
problem here is that for instance chess
has a state space of around 10 to the
power of 120 which means that this
spreadsheet approach with the cue tables
doesn't really scale in to the real
world but we can steal a trick from the
media compression world which is trade
some accuracy for memory because storing
a video a 1080p video at 60fps per
second takes about 1 gigabyte with
lossless compression and if you add some
loss in then you can take the hit with
the accuracy and because it's still
going to be good enough right and it's
gonna be usually or at least in
deepmind's opinion it's going to be
better than humans and that's gonna make
a data scientist smile so you can see
here this kind of looks like the other
figure I showed you guys you have their
environment on the right it gives a
state and reward to the agent the agent
does take that state and the reward and
it uses the neural network it Maps the
state into the input layer of the neural
network and it finds the policy which
means it finds the optimal action to
make in that state and then it takes
that action into the environment and
then it goes on pretty similar to the
cue table approach there's a couple of
things we need to do when we introduce
neural networks though one thing we can
do is make the update function a lot
more simple because the learning rate is
no longer needed because the
backpropagation optimizer already have
that in neural networks so the learning
rate is simply like a global gas pedal
and one does not need to
of these once learning rate is removed
you realize that you also can remove the
two cue terms because they cancel cancel
each other out and then you're just
stuck with the reward plus the discount
times the maximum Q value in the next
state and so let's simpler this formula
another thing you need to do is I
mentioned briefly to map the state into
a into the input layer of neural
networks because neural networks they
don't take strings they only use numbers
so you need to map a state to a number
or a vector of numbers or an array and
for this you can use one hot encoding
how many of you guys are familiar with
with what not encoding okay so almost
everyone I'm still gonna explain it to
those who don't know what it is so why
not encoding is usually used on
categorical values we can use this
example we have three colors we have red
green and blue right so you can't just
put those strings into a neural network
because it needs numbers so what you
could do then is to assign an integer
for each of these categories so red you
can give one for instance green becomes
two and blue becomes three
now the problem there is that when you
feed this to a neural network everyone
here agrees that 3 is bigger than 1
right so you're kind of telling the
neural network that blue is bigger than
red which doesn't really make any sense
so what you do is that you assign a
vector instead of an integer and these
vectors the example you can see here the
red then becomes 1 0 0 green can be 0 0
1 and blue can be 0 1 0 the length of
these vectors are the same and therefore
the neural network doesn't see any value
greater than the other it just sees it
at different values this we're using to
map the state of the pacman into an
input to the neural network you can see
here I don't know if you all of you can
see it I'll show it
better detail later but basically we
take the string we have a string
representation of the state and then you
just start at the top left of the state
and you just walk through it you make a
an empty string or an empty empty array
I mean not empty string and then you
just go through each character and you
just add this one hot encoding and what
its gonna look like is something like
this the state is the down to the left
here that's the start State in level 0
when you use this what haunt encoding
it's gonna be this long array of just
numbers but this is a new unique
representation of that state so in real
network when it gets fed this into the
input layer it's gonna know okay we're
talking about this state now and then
yeah I can it can differentiate between
different states what the neural network
then does is that given this input array
it can then return to us
aq value of all four actions in that
state so the actions here there's four
float numbers here as you can see the
left the firsts item in the list is the
Q value for moving left and then it's up
and right and down so the best action
here is gonna be the first item which is
going to be moved to the left so if you
exploit here then the agent is going to
move to the left we also need to
introduce something called experience
replay so instead of training online we
save an experience to a memory bank and
then we train on random samples from the
memory bank online training is what we
do with the Q value the agent performs
an action this is immediately updated in
the Q table and then you do the next
action and so on but what we want to do
instead with neural networks and deep Q
learning is that when a when the agent
performs an action you don't immediately
update the q-value and and train the
neural network but instead you save it
to a memory bank and then you draw
random samples from this memory bank the
reason for this there's three reasons
the first one is that deep view neural
networks they tend to forget early runs
so if the agent of the Pegman agent
starts to train on a specific level then
after solving like getting halfway
through the level it'll start trained on
the later part of the the level right
and then if you just update the q-value
continuously then it might forget the
first part of the level and then when
it's episode ends and it's supposed to
know the first part it doesn't know it
anymore so that's why we need to sample
from this bank so it can take random
random experiences from it it's also a
really efficient use of a previous
experience because it can learn each
move multiple times this is key when
gaining for instance real world
experience is costly and you can get the
full use of it by training multiple
times the cube learning updates are
incremental and they don't converge too
quickly so multiple passes with the same
data is kind of beneficial it also
reduces correlation between experiences
it's not that great if the neural
network learned that certain states
follow certain previous states based on
an action performed in previous States
it's not really wanted because the world
is not really deterministic for instance
in pac-man the goals they don't take the
same action in every state they can do
some random actions so you don't want to
learn a correlation between certain
states okay and with that I think we can
go over to the next coding challenge
here
let's see all right looks pretty good if
you guys didn't follow on assignment one
is fine you can ask us later if you want
to continue with it there's also the
assignment one answers
notebook right underneath it which gives
out what we just code it in we're going
to go to assignment two now yeah if you
can turn off the lights again
whoever did that that would be nice I
can see that the mic doesn't really get
my voice before I like bow down but I
hope everyone could hear me
I'm sorry oh yeah their next-door mic is
working really well all right cool so
let's start with the deep Q learning
method as manure previously said the
first cell is just to import packages
there's one thing you guys should know
about this and is that the jupiter
notebooks the VM that it's running on it
has two GPUs connected to it with 12
gigabyte of RAM each previously when we
held this workshop we ran out of memory
and everything just crashed so we added
this everyone here can use 2% of the GPU
memory but we are a lot of people here
today more than expected so we'll see
what happens if everyone gets on it
should be fine so don't don't change
this number up here too much yeah
secondly were you seeing chaos as you
said it's a really high level wrapper
around neural networks that if you're
new you definitely recommend doing that
tensor field two just came out and it
also has Karis built in and I barely
tried it but it seems to work pretty
well again you run the cell by pressing
shift enter there's nothing to do in the
first cell and the second cell we define
all the rewards we're gonna use some
slightly different rewards it's also
there's two things to think about when
you do the rewards menu and mentioned
one of them which is that you have to
make sure that the relationship between
the values are coherent or make sense
and the other one is that the values
shouldn't get too verbose or too big or
too high for instance I wouldn't
recommend putting anything in here that
gives the larger reward than 20 or
anything that gets less or more
punishment than minus 20 so try to keep
it in 20 minus 20 distance also these
values are just values that we
experience it with and it worked pretty
well but there are not the optimal
values so if you guys want to try to do
this yourselves
there are definitely better rewards than
this but I'm gonna give one for getting
a dot and then - five - if you're
captured by a ghost
and then the nun and wall I'm gonna give
- point one again just to move penalty
like we knew briefly explained if you
don't want the pac-man to run around in
circles getting zero points and then go
to the end you want him to reach the
finish as fast as possible I'm gonna
give ten for winning and then I'm gonna
give minus ten for losing yeah and these
are not optimal if you guys want to try
you can just put in some other values
might work better than what we have so
here is the state - input of the neural
network mapping function it gets the
string representation from the state it
makes an empty array and then it just
loops through the whole string and makes
this one hot encoding of the state
there's nothing to do there then we have
to define the model so one thing that's
kind of important that many we also
briefly mentioned is that the input size
of the neural network it depends on the
size of the state right because if you
have a bigger bigger state when you loop
over it then you will have a longer
vector and then you will have a bigger
input layer so we're just so that's this
input size input size here determines
the state the size of the input layer of
the neural network and then we need
to find a number of actions because that
decides the size of the output layer so
we're gonna just do the length of action
get all actions can you know you cannot
autocomplete was not here because as I
showed you earlier
the neural network then returns four
values and each of these values are the
Q values for moving left up right and
down so we can see here this is the
Karis API we make a sequential model you
add the first hidden layer here and as
you can see the input layer is kind of
embedded into it so we know that the
input shape is the input size right
there were already defined then we have
one hidden layer with size 256 neurons
and then we have another hidden layer
with size 128 and then when we need to
make the output layer which is also just
a dense layer with the size of the
number of actions because we want for
four values yes this should be correct
you can run it it should give some
warnings that's perfect
some deprecated okay then we have made
our neural network model with five code
lines it's pretty easy then we have the
picked optimal action that we also had
in the cue cue table assignment this
time it just it predicts use the model
the neural network to predict which is
the better action there nothing to do
here and here also you can change the
expiration probability it's set to point
two here as well one thing that kind of
enhances the performance a little bit is
to use decaying exploration probability
which means that earlier early in the
training process use a really high
exploration
probability for instance 50% so it's
gonna see a lot of the state space and
it's gonna really explore the whole the
whole world and then as the training
goes on this value gets smaller and
smaller and at the end there's almost no
exploration but only exploitation so it
really goes in and sees and uses the
exploitation yeah right yeah you're just
going to set it for point two for now
and there's nothing else to do here
and then this is the experience replay
that I mentioned we are implementing
this with two classes it's a memory
class which is the memory bank it holds
a lot of experiences and then there's
the experience class here I don't know
explain that after the memory so the
memory is a double-ended queue or a deck
we set it to a size of 5,000 the
important thing to know about this is
that as the first 5,000 experiences come
in the order matters so that when the
item number 5,000 or experience number
5,000 one comes in it's the last one
that gets popped out so the older
experiences they're forgotten so that we
keep the relevant ones that one that we
have learned and pop out the older ones
so we had we have a add method to just
add and experience the memory we have a
get I've get a mini batch which we're
going to use which is samples all the
random experiences of this batch size
and then we have a get size the
experience it contains all the
information that we need to train the
neural network at one time so it's gonna
it contains the current state it
contains an action that's performed in
that state
it contains the reward you got for that
action and it contains the next state
that the environment returned and then
it's also there's a flag here done
because we need to know if it's a
terminal State or not I'm gonna come
back to that so this is just an
experience and the memory is just a big
collection of this of these experience
I don't think we need to I don't need to
do anything here okay
so to the training loop where the fun
stuff happens you initialize game state
and you make the memory bank what size
5000 you can make bigger to if you want
to then you start training pouring
through the number of training episodes
by the way this game is a co-worker of
of us made it and it uses for instance
deep copy method by Python and that's a
really slow method so this game is not
optimized for using for machine learning
because it's really slow but it works it
works good enough as they say then while
the episode is not done while he's not
dead or have won the game you pick an
action you get the next game state and
the action event and the same here as in
the assignment one we need to know if
it's terminal state I'm gonna come back
to that and when if we know when this is
done then we can calculate the reward
and then we need instead now in the cue
table assignment we just in the cue
table assignment we immediately updated
the Q value now but what we're gonna do
we're gonna make an experience we're
gonna add it to the memory bank and then
we're gonna get a mini batch from the
memory and then we're going to Train it
from that so we store a new experience
or just make a new experience object
where we put in all of these parameters
here that uses in the constructor so we
set the current state I want also one
important thing to notice is that
we need to convert the state to the to
the input so we can just easily just
take experiences from the memory bank
and just plug it in to plug it into the
neural network so we're going to convert
it before we put it into the experience
all right
I'm just plugging this the next one is
action I believe which is just action
then you have reward next state and done
so it's do a reward next state we also
need to convert this one remember that
next state is called next aim state and
then done is done so we have this new
experience we add it to the memory bank
we already initialized the memory object
so we just use the add function add the
experience and then we get that we need
to get a mini batch from it which is
this one right here
I'm married get me a batch and then you
need the batch size but I think it is
already I created so we just write this
okay I think yeah we're gonna write
sighs okay
so now we have gathered these
experiences from the memory bank and
what happens further down here is that
it creates the training data to train
the neural network we make the features
which is the state representation in the
vector and then we made the targets
which are all the actions or the Q
values it's important that you only
train one action you can only train the
action that you performed so you can't
train the other three actions and the
reason we need to know if the terminal
state is or if we are in terminal state
is that the target value is simply going
to become the reward if it's terminal
state if it's not the terminal state we
need to use the Q value update formula
so it's going to look like this the
reward plus gamma times the maximum Q
value of the next state so we have about
ten minutes left so you have to move on
yeah then we just update some parameters
we deep copy again because that's fun
and then we can try to run our training
or we can run the we can define our
training method and then you can do this
we're not going to run this one you guys
can run this one if you guys want you
can run here you chose the number of
training episodes you should probably
just start with level zero and the batch
size we're gonna take 100 from the
memory bank out maybe change this one to
something like 32 it's a little bit
smaller
it's gonna update then you'll network
more often it's gonna also be slower but
yeah so let's see how this works out so
I have pre trained one oops
effort so i pre-trained one I trained a
deep Q Network agent on a different
level than the level zero we made that's
the one that my new show didn't start
let's see here if everything is correct
yeah let's see okay so I trained it for
5,000 episodes on level 2 it's called
it's up in here in the boards can you
see anything
yeah 500 is fine for now because I'm
going to show you guys how the pac-man
performs at episode number 500 and a
2500 and at the end at 4,500 I trained
this on my GPU at home I have a gtx TI
1080 it's a bit outdated now and it
trained for about 26 hours yeah so let's
see if I run this now so this is after
500 episodes the Pechman has now played
the game 500 times and it does pretty
well in the beginning but as we can see
it's also important to note that these
mushrooms I don't know how well you guys
can see it in the back but the mushrooms
they make the ghosts scared so if you
run into the ghosts after you take a
mushroom then the ghosts is dying and
not yourself but now I can see we're at
the kind of the end game and the pac-man
is a little bit confused where to go
because in 500 episodes it hasn't really
reached this far it has learned the
start of the game and it helps a little
bit that the map is quite simple but
here it died three times so the game the
game is over so let's try with 2500
let's not try with 2500 because it's not
here let's try with 3000 so this is
after 3,000 games played hopefully it
should be a little bit better but it's
still mostly won't solve the problem as
we'll see I think I'm regretting a
little bit that I made put so many
mushrooms in this level because the
ghosts are just kind of permanently
scared and pretty useless so you can
definitely make a harder board for the
pac-man let's see if he's able to solve
it not when they're blue now they can
kill the pac-man yeah when they're kind
of like lighter than peckmon can kill
them
so it actually managed to win the level
here and it's actually pretty fast this
probably happens around 50/50 where we
can see later on when the training kind
of is that its latest stages the pac-man
actually becomes pretty smart and will
actually run in a straight line to all
the dots and be able to solve it pretty
quickly but yeah now the ghosts are like
light light blue flash green so if they
run into pac-man now they're the ghosts
are the one that dies and not the
pac-man itself I should not have put
this many mushrooms in in the map so
let's see here it's running away from
the ghost if you guys saw that it's a
pretty interesting that also seen is
that the ghost was running after the
pac-man or one more time the ghost was
running after the pac-man and the
pac-man could have survived but I think
that the pac-man had learned that it can
just die and use one of its lifes
because then it spawns in the middle of
the map and then it's gonna be faster to
reach the other dots so it can learn
some things like that too and it all
depends of the relationship between your
rewards because if you really put a
heavy punishment and dying then it won't
do that but if you put kind of a light
reward or punishment for dying
then he will there he just moved into
the ghost and he spawns in the middle
and then he runs and solves the problem
so that's pretty fun you can learn stuff
like that yeah so there is seven minutes
left so I have a couple of more slides
okay so just fast at the very end here
before we take some questions there are
some obviously some improvements to this
this is kind of the baseline of deep Q
neural networks you can use decaying
exploration a probability that I
mentioned you can use convolutional
layers because convolutional layers
they're really good with the 2d data so
that's why it's all often used on images
and stuff and the pac-man game board is
2d so it probably will enhance the
performance a little bit obviously more
training time more memory and more
processing power is gonna make the
training faster and and converge faster
there's also something called a target
to use something called the target and
neural network which during training
when you train this network the Q values
they actually change from the beginning
of the training until the end so they
learn different things during the
training time which kind of confuses the
neural network a little bit so you can
use two neural networks instead which
means more stable training and then you
can also use something called
prioritized experience replay sampling
so instead of taking random experiences
from the memory you can kind of
prioritize what kind of experiences you
want let's say that your agent is
struggling earlier in the game then you
can say okay well we we want to take
experiences that happened earlier in the
game and then train on those so there no
network will perform better there
and yeah I think that is it for us we'll
take some questions is if anyone has
yeah yeah you do you mean the cue table
or the deep cue yes yeah okay repeat the
question if if they if memory wasn't a
constraint would you guys get the same
results on the cue table as we did and
yes you would definitely even even with
the constraint because the GPU
constraints are not applied on the
assignment one so that the acute table
that assignment one you can definitely
with what we just did now you can
definitely get the same results yeah
if you plot in the same yeah on the
Jupiter in and on the cue table it's
pretty fast because we only use it on
the level zero right it's the easiest
it's the easiest map because it doesn't
really scale too big your Maps so on the
easy map on the level 0 map you it will
able conversion it will work pretty well
yeah yeah yes yes
so the question is why don't you learn
take longer to train because think
you're learning you have to search the
state space while in the neural network
in deep coloring you don't have to
search the whole state space and the
answer to that do they have any good
answer I'm thinking as the question the
problem is that on the cue table version
of this we can't make bigger maps
because then then it won't like it won't
scale right because you have to hold the
whole cue table in memory at the same
time yeah and if memory wasn't a
constraint yeah if you can't then I mean
sure then it would converge to at some
point but you would also need to explore
all the states right to get the optimal
solution because the update state step
itself is the same for both methods kind
of yeah I don't know if that answered
your question yeah we get in there you
can talk later if you want to after the
after the session yeah any other
questions
I mean if okay so let's say you're the
agent yourself and okay there sorry
about that
the question is I said that if you're
the agent then the environment is kind
of the laws of physics and the rules of
society and if I can get an example of
that so an example could be you yourself
are an agent and you jump out of a
window on the third floor then you're
going to hurt yourself
because of the laws of physics and that
is kind of a punishment reward from the
environment from the the laws of physics
and in the rules of society example for
instance if you go out and hit someone
in the face your police is probably
going to come and maybe arrest you or
something and that's a punishment from
the from the society that you shouldn't
run around and punch people in the face
[Laughter]
during training that you will learn
different values or you mean like the
rewards if they increase in decrease
yeah okay that's a good question
obviously you're wondering if the
rewards could like change during
training because the cue now is they do
change right yeah it's an interesting
third there's an interesting thought I
have not tried that myself
it will also be pretty weird because if
you change the rewards then kind of
everything you trained up to that point
would be a little bit useless yeah
because it depends on like why would you
want to change them right there should
be like a reason to change them like
like maybe the
the reward is like this reward is less
important like this event is less
important at some point then it makes
sense to change them right but like
picking up a dot and not dying in
pac-man it's equally important the whole
way right so it doesn't kind of make
sense to change them but like in other
applications then maybe yeah I've never
tried it
yeah
for instance that could be a way to go
different levels in pac-man you can
change the reward for each level because
some level maybe you need it to be a
higher reward for picking up a dot or
else the agent won't converge that fast
yeah that could be a thing thank you for
the questions I think we're out of time
right I have one more one more
do we have time for one more there's a
nod it can get stuck it can get stuck
but usually as long as your rewards is
like thought-out and you use the two
rules that we talked about then it will
often converge to a good solution yeah I
think they will not necessarily do the
same solution I believe at least yeah we
were just based all this on observation
but but I mean if you're gonna do this
properly you would use like statistic
methods to like kind of measure how
successful you are right okay all right
thank you very much if you guys want to
ask us anything else you guys can just
find us after like right now actually
[Laughter]
you
[Applause]